il a effectué ses premiers pas à
l'assemblée nationale en octobre dernier
philippe benassaya nouveau député de la
11e circonscription des yvelines a pris
le rythme de l'activité parlementaire
une journée type c'est à la fois des
rencontres des rendez vous du travail
beaucoup beaucoup d'études travail de
commission sur toutes les thématiques
sur lesquelles je suis engagé donc ce
sont des journées chargées en général le
mardi le mercredi et le jeudi
premier point au programme de sa matinée
une question orale une séance
particulière dans l'hémicycle avec une
question individuelle et directe du
parlementaire aux membres du
gouvernement le député yvelinois va
solliciter la ministre déléguée au
logement auprès de la ministre de la
transition écologique
madame la ministre attire votre
attention sur les difficultés que
rencontre le personnel pénitentiaire
pour se loger notamment dans le logement
social
plus généralement les modalités
d'application de la loi sru pose de
grosses difficultés aux communes ce
sujet philippe benassaya le connaît à
travers la maison d'arrêt présente à
bois d'arcy ancien maire de cette
commune cette fonction d'élu local lui
permet d'agir aussi dans sa nouvelle
activité de législateurs une expérience
remarquer par ses collègues du groupe
l'est républicain pendant l'impression
qu'il veut d'un sérieux à être toujours
été à l'assemblée nationale tellement il
connaît ses sujets il maîtrise ses
dossiers surtout c'est un homme de
terrain un racine est ancrée qui défend
des valeurs d'autorité mais aussi de
solidarité
on sent qu'il a une expérience d'élu
local comme j'ai pu l'être moi même et
le fait d'avoir été maire de bois d'arcy
lui donne évidemment une familiarité
avec beaucoup de sujets après la réunion
du groupe parlementaire les lui vinoir
rejoint son bureau
membre de la commission des finances
engagé sur les sujets de sécurité
philippe benassaya a déjà travaillé sur
plusieurs textes de loi notamment à
travers des amendements
j'ai fait un amendement sur la police
sur l'essai et sud et centre de
supervision urbain je prends un exemple
dans ma circonscription pour être
toujours très concret le mini de sony
est dans une petite communauté de
communes
ça permettra aux minimes deux familles
de pouvoir se rattacher à la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin pour
bénéficier des ces sur le lien avec sa
circonscription le député des
républicains le conserve avec son rôle
d'élu départemental face à la loi du non
cumul des mandats il a été contrainte de
démissionner de sa fonction de maire
ça c'était un vrai crève-coeur très
honnêtement j'ai mis un peu de temps à
passer du rôle de mère à députés donc la
transition n'a pas été évidente puis
maintenant ça va puisque je garde
toujours bien sûr un oeil sur sur sur
bois d'arcy et sur l'ensemble des villes
de la circonscription pour conserver son
ancrage local philippe benassaya sera
candidat pour un nouveau mandat de
conseiller départemental pour le scrutin
de juin 2021